( intro music )
( applause )
Good evening.
Working for the
National Geographic
has been the best
experience that I can imagine.
It's hard to translate
that into emotion
to something other
people can understand.
When I was growing
up, I was not the guy
that people would
have expected
to have the career
of his dreams.
First, I was born
in Hays, Kansas.
Which is not the intersection
of art, culture, and science.
( audience laughter )
And on top of that
school was really difficult.
Not just hard,
but I was dyslexic.
And I had a hard time
reading, writing,
anything that had to do
with school, except for art,
was difficult for me.
And I have to think
back to a family trip
in 1975,
in Grand Lake, Colorado.
I took my parents' camera,
I ran down to the lake
and I shot a picture
of a sailboat.
But for me it's ironic that I
am essentially doing something
to fill my time,
that I was hooked.
So I was lucky.
I got to work at Kansas State
at this great newspaper,
The Collegian.
And then I got an internship
atThe Philadelphia Inquirer.
So, I did a story about
Greg Tutt, a boxer
who trained in Joe Frazier's
gym and worked really hard.
I admired his dedication
and his hard work.
I remember the
article really well.
It ran in the Sunday magazine.
It was written by a well-known
writer, Steve Lopez.
And the opening line
of the story was
"Greg Tutt is walking
through a neighborhood
that's going nowhere and
taking everybody with it."
And, to me, you know I had to
in a sense compete
on the same page
as people who could
write like that.
So, it was very important to
me to work as hard as I could
to deserve a place
at that table.
And working in
Philadelphia led me
to another amazing opportunity.
I'd always wanted to work
forSports Illustrated.
I'd done a lot of my
college work in sports.
A guy named Buzz Bissinger
who was a writer at
The Philadelphia Inquirer
won a Pulitzer,
and I had heard that
he was leaving the
newspaper to go do a book
about high school
football in Texas.
And I went up and showed him
the work and I said, you know
"You should hire me to go
do that work for you."
And it worked out.
I moved to Odessa,
Texas for a while and
shot pictures for a
book,Friday Night Lights,
which is, you know, turned
into the TV show and the movie
and all these things.
We were looking at race, at
the boom-bust cycle of oil,
parents living
through their kids.
This is the quarterback of
the team, Mike Winchell
who is always
kind of a loner
because of all the
pressure on him.
And this is still one of
my favorite pictures.
Not just from that
book but you know
I really enjoyed
this picture.
They had 5:30 AM
call for football
five days a week,
double practices.
They worked harder
than most people do.
And then they lost.
They lost to Midland Lee,
their archrivals,
which for me, a lot of
my sports photography
I enjoy the winning and
the losing photos.
I like action pictures,
but I was kind of
always more drawn to the
emotion in the pictures.
But also there is a serious side
to some of the work I was doing.
I live in
Williamsburg, Brooklyn
and I was getting ready to
leave the country on the 12th
for a trip to Thailand for...
for a story for the magazine.
And, you know, I got a
call from my fiancée
and she said, "a plane hit
the World Trade Center."
And I looked at the
building, and I could--
I actually had a view of that.
So I ran to the roof
of my building.
I got to the roof at
like, 8:58 or so.
And, you know, I was just
composing the picture
with the smoke going downtown.
These are...
pictures I shot that
ran inTIMEmagazine.
I am very conflicted
about these images
but it is a very big
part of my career.
I'm glad that I did
my job correctly.
This horrible situation, it's
a horrible thing to watch.
But I do realize they're
important pictures
and I'm happy that
I've done work
that is now in
history books.
And... I had some pictures in
a book about war photography
and exhibited at the Corcoran,
there's a film and there's a...
military historian talking
about my pictures and he said
and I hadn't thought about it
this way at all, he said that
"it's very rare that you have
a picture of a war starting."